you
for what is a man what has he got if not
himself then he has naught what's
happening you bad [ __ ] uncle
Joey here August September 15th the day
the devil was buried at sea and [ __ ]
in the ass and [ __ ] purgatory
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's Monday grab your boss it's all
about [ __ ] the heart today a sling
and Dicky and giving our [ __ ]
mouthwash you understand me that's what
your [ __ ] words are in your heart
today we're here we're queer
you know Denver [ __ ] the best city
I'm obvious smoking some [ __ ] [ __ ]
tremendous for my people in Denver
native roots they hooked me up with some
[ __ ] I don't even know what it's
called does it really matter it don't
give a [ __ ] look what strain is that
Joey
that [ __ ] nutsack that's what
straining is I don't know I don't ask I
just tell him I want this [ __ ] to [ __ ]
made him jump up and down they give it
to me I go home and I smoke it I don't
ask no [ __ ] quit is it a sativa
hybrid or does it have an indica dot
listen it doesn't [ __ ] matter okay
knock it off with the [ __ ] stupid
questions so you could try to be cool
when it [ __ ] front of your [ __ ]
goofy little friend
tremendous was a fantastic weekend in
Denver I love you [ __ ] five
sold-out shows you all came out that's
why I love you anyway I'm a little
[ __ ] stoned you just hit me like a
smack to the face tonight three o'clock
podcasts be there be square who's them
of them Reseda with my boys Thursday I'm
at some [ __ ] army thing and Friday
I'm at the ice house to expand this
[ __ ] I was when we get this [ __ ] I'll
on October 15th there's no [ __ ]
misunderstanding you understand me you
get what the [ __ ] you came for uncle
Joey in full effect
the pays to smoke the best in this damn
it I got two brands today I got this
death from [ __ ] Colorado and I got
some death from around the corner some
[ __ ] Disney this [ __ ] comes with a
[ __ ] aspirin you understand me it
comes with a knows things you can
[ __ ] put it under your nose and come
back to that's the type of weed you want
[ __ ] so that's it that's that
that the Icehouse this week
oh [ __ ] then we got Austin [ __ ]
Texas its September it's my only taxes
that I can't wait I'm bring Italy three
days of [ __ ] pathos and papacito's
that's it that's the only thing I eat
when I'm there for three days this week
like I didn't in three days I did eight
meals at Sam's that's how old-school I
am he understand me loyalty to me means
flopped in everything eight meals at
Sam's I got that Thursday at 12 o'clock
I had lunch and dinner and all three
meals on Saturday and Sunday of Sam's I
did not deviate that's a type of
[ __ ] I am that's a type of
loyalty
we command if you want to get there
because everything else is background
music you know two weeks ago half you
[ __ ] are jumping up and down
with Bernie Sanders was Bernie Sanders
now he's hanging out in the [ __ ]
bathroom they forgot about them do you
understand me
we don't forget here we don't [ __ ]
forget and enjoy what's with the [ __ ]
me oh [ __ ] some [ __ ] Disney
whiz knee for you yeah - wheezing are
you people were jumping up and down with
many sins we're nice and this is Sun
we're [ __ ] contemplating to Robin
Williams because nobody even [ __ ]
call from them the [ __ ] wrong you'd
be
the loyalty guys loyalty it means
everything I still talk to my friends
from the [ __ ] sixth grade because I
don't give a [ __ ] about these hunks you
think I'm thinking that with Matt Damon
oh is that gonna do feet you think
Matt's gonna bail you out when you stab
[ __ ] in the neck get your [ __ ]
together people no wonder you're
supposed to put on Jared Jared was a
[ __ ] Punk
he was even small [ __ ] kids [ __ ]
he was doing something
I wanted you to pay off my [ __ ] blue
belt wearing a pride even though I don't
deserve it I'm no blue belt but I got
nothing but I understand and I keep
showing up that's the [ __ ] thing
keeps showing up
you drive me [ __ ] crazy you don't say
the best revenge is to just [ __ ] be
there you ever think about that just be
there set my ex-wife and then wish you
don't know what the [ __ ] going on I'm
still alive I'm not getting high the
cops and look before me she knows like a
show up at that [ __ ] fireplace naked
with [ __ ] three knives and she knows
because I'm out there that's the
scariest thought you could ever play on
people yeah out there joy which what the
[ __ ] any of beat miss Mona would you do
tonight through bumps a blow man I took
it out for brain yeah I did my [ __ ]
smoothie but I'm in milk and this is the
result understand you could go a little
wreath run or what he expected
have I told you people I love smoking
[ __ ] refund it's tremendous you could
save all that other [ __ ] drinking at a
bar with a bunch of spear for the hat on
hey there's tops are often what we're
doing right here come on
we're doing right here this is like we
[ __ ] get ourselves motivated on a
Monday morning to go out there and stab
a [ __ ]
while we're smoking a joint who talks
you this way nobody you know what cuz
I'm the last of the Mohicans just like
you yeah I'm saying that that's it
that's what it's all about a little
reason you do some jumping jacks you
write your goals and you do the best you
can I love the smell away from the boy
one more ball I'm gonna go to the
perennial and pick up my [ __ ] mix for
the week and I already got the stars at
that for the week I got listen I got to
his ass that was given to me in Denver I
got [ __ ] mushrooms with chocolate
listen there's gonna be a big week on
the church don't [ __ ] around
clear your schedule I think it's today
at 3:00 and then Wednesday I don't know
what time but one of these nights were
going deeper than deep people gonna die
that's why I gotta tell you okay
did I tell you I'm [ __ ] spelling to
the gills I really have I don't even
know how this happened we came out here
we chit-chatted and this is it
are you kidding me or what you had some
[ __ ] look at you looking good
today sexy [ __ ] coming to
Austin Texas but late wanna tear it up
that New York City it's Kentucky you
[ __ ] don't know what to get I
haven't worked this hard and [ __ ] ten
years trying to put this [ __ ] special
together leave believe Monsanto we got
some [ __ ] animals out there it's
gonna forget today's Monday
ain't no looking back okay who gives a
[ __ ] about Diaz and McGregor gets a [ __ ]
about that [ __ ] that's Saturday today's
Monday are you gonna [ __ ] her and
donate [ __ ] that's the [ __ ]
question what are you gonna do you're
gonna walk on coals and tell your
friends let's meet at Starbucks and
discuss the future what future the
futures and your nutsack slinging didn't
giving out drop a bomb in that juice
that's it that's that it's all on the
table you know I'm saying there's no
[ __ ] elephant in the room you know
exactly what to do in the state of mind
and the technology that you need that's
it your iPhone nothing could give you
what I got to give you this is right
here in your mind and you go out next to
you and I said [ __ ]
it's all up to you now you got a sling
dick today I can't do none for you
yeah I'm up there and put a statue of
your dick on the table although there
you don't sniff in the suck and I'm like
and it's your choice got a second I
gotta go take care [ __ ] I gotta go right
back I don't send emails I got a [ __ ]
a jujitsu michael total kettlebells are
on I'm gonna do mobility class now we
got the podcast at 3:00 and tonight I'm
going out to torture some [ __ ]
and that's the bottom line all right
tip-top Magoo who gives a [ __ ] it's too
old to that's it it's the week of
[ __ ] you who gives a [ __ ] about these
[ __ ] they don't put money in
your pocket Friday we'll talk about a
little put money in your pocket on
Saturday
this I don't know what my [ __ ] paper
clip is I'm down to a new [ __ ] title
thing this is like a spear for the
eyeball here you know me though I'm
conservative anyway I love you
[ __ ] have a phenomenal day write
your goals eat your vitamins and do your
push-ups I love you stay black see you
around [ __ ] them quarter to three with
it and that's it don't take [ __ ] from
nobody till it's your world they're just
something visit